more terrible news sort of a depressing
first segment today police in Toronto
have arrested a man who drove a white
van onto a sidewalk in the northern part
of Toronto killed 10 people injured 15
the details are more or less what you
would expect a totally chaotic scene a
damaged van injured and dead people
sprawled across the sidewalk glass
debris police everywhere notable is that
when police showed up and there's video
of this the suspect appeared to be
pointing a handgun at police and
actually saying shoot me in the head and
Toronto police did not shoot the guy and
the guy actually says I have a gun in my
pocket takes out what could have been a
gun wasn't a gun it's been reported that
it was actually a mobile phone said
shoot me in the head and police didn't
shoot the guy and ultimately were able
to take him into custody at another
point it really does seem like this was
an attempt for suicide by cop by this
alleged perpetrator and it is very very
difficult to imagine that in the hands
of many police departments this ends up
with anything other than a dead suspect
right I think it is actually in the
midst of what is a horrible tragedy a
sort of interesting footnote that this
is a suspect that would have ended up
dead if confronted by many other police
departments and was taken into custody
and maybe hopefully we will eventually
learn of the motive which we don't yet
know right there's a tentative
identification of the alleged shooter
he's a 25 year old male we do know that
generally speaking the use of vehicles
to kill people on sidewalks recently has
been sort of the calling card of the mo
of of radical Islamic terrorists we will
see what ultimately turns up here we
don't know if that's ultimately going to
be the case here and the only thing that
we know at this point is number one
police say that this was deliberate not
an out-of-control car or someone may be
having some kind of a medical incident
leading them to inadvertently drive up
onto a curb in case anybody thought
those were probabilities police are
saying this was definitely deliberate
and what is being reported is that a
message
was posted to a Facebook account
believed to belong to the driver earlier
yesterday which said quote all hail the
supreme gentleman Elliot Roger Roger
which is very very creepy to say the
least Elliot Rodger if the name rings a
bell was the 22 year old who back in May
of 2014 killed six people and injured 14
sort of near the campus of UC Santa
Barbara when he stabbed three men to
death in his apartment then went to a
sorority house and shot three female
students killing two of them then went
to I believe it was a deli and shot dead
a male student inside sped through a
nearby area shooting and wounding more
pedestrians hitting others with his car
exchanging gunfire with police at two
different points during the attack and
eventually crashing his car into a
parked vehicle and being found dead
after a self-inflicted shotgun wound
so if accurate the fact that the suspect
in the Toronto case yesterday seemed to
be praising another mass killer is
disturbing and it's also a little bit of
a window into the type of incident that
this appears to be and there's one other
interesting statement in a CNN article
about this and it references men's
rights activism as a possible catalyst
for this incident and the men's rights
activists are losing their minds online
about this the quote from the CNN
article is that investigators said
Rodger was motivated to carry out his
attack by a personal grievance related
to his immersion in the extremist
ideological subculture of men's rights
activists who believe women don't
actually want gender equality and have
been brainwashed by feminist propaganda
and men's rights activists online are
saying wait a second why in an article
that's supposedly mostly about
yesterday's shooter are you talking
about the alleged men's rights activist
views of the guy from 2014 it doesn't
make any sense and I don't know that I
have too much else to say about that but
interesting that that seems to be what
has completely triggered the men's
rights activists online we will see what
else we learn
about this incident we will see what
else we learn about the motive but I
think if there's any good news at all in
what are two really horrible stories
over the last 24 hours number one the
Waffle House shooting in Tennessee
number two this vehicular murder
effectively in Toronto the only bit of
good news that I can point to is that
both suspects were taken alive
and that provides potentially a
different ability to debrief and to gain
insight into what it is that took place
here very very sad incidents I welcome
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on Twitter a David Pakman
show we will take a quick break and be
back after this
today's program is sponsored in part by
foo tour the tour is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you open up the
game on your phone or web browser you'll
see a whole range of forecasts covering
topics across the board politics sports
so much more you wager on predictions
about real world events using food tours
in game fake currency and you earn more
of this currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account by
clicking the link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube and this
week on futur I posed the question will
robert molars trump russia investigation
end during this year during 2018 what do
you think place your bets and you can
sign up now at fruit or calm and start
making your forecasts on political
topics and so many other topics it's
free and it's available on both Android
and iOS as well as on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm